hey if you have a moment check out our
online store at anime out Broadcom we
have exclusive designs created by pro
manga artist Kazuma including s Kannur
praised the Sun meliodas feel the wrath
and for a limited time all transiting
shaggy one-shotting Thanos because yes
that's a thing all the proceeds directly
support more content on this channel so
check it out link in the description
[Music]
what is up everybody at Santa Mack here
for anime out bro and in this video I
will be talking about possibly my
all-time favorite seven deadly sins
character bandha bandit aka
undead bond aka fairy king Vaughan aka
the foxes sin of greed yes he has a lot
of names and as much as I love meliodas
ESCA Noir and mile my other favorite
seven deadly sins characters there will
always be a special place in my heart
for bond but why do I in so many others
love bond when he is first introduced
bond is portrayed as a depressed
masochist whose favorite pastimes are
apparently fighting stealing and getting
drunk
not exactly the profile of a battle
shown in hero and at first bond appears
to be more of an antihero especially
when King accuses him of killing his
sister Elaine and destroying the fairy
Kings forest just so he could drink from
the Fountain of Youth and obtain
immortality and we can't really blame
King for thinking this since that is the
exact crime that bond was charged with
this was his sin and he spent years in
prison because of it he was even
sentenced to death but he couldn't be
executed because he was immortal so he
just spent his time getting tortured and
dungeons and the crazy thing about all
of this is that bond doesn't even try to
defend himself from these accusations or
to escape from prison which is
especially interesting when we learned
that bond did not do what he is being
accused of on the contrary he tried to
save the fairy Kings forest from a red
demon and not only did he not kill
Elaine he loved Elaine and although he
did his best to save her in the end she
sacrificed her own life to save him so
bond lost the woman he loved and not
only that but she died in his arms and
to make things worse bond always felt
horribly guilty and responsible for
Elaine's death while fighting the red
demon bond didn't realize the demons had
more than one heart and that mistake led
to Elaine's death because she sacrificed
her own life to save him bond is so
distraught and oppressed by this
traumatic event that he just doesn't
care about anything anymore
he is immortal so he cannot die no
matter how much damage is inflicted upon
him which means that he is cursed to
live forever with crippling guilt over
what happened to a
he allows himself to be arrested and he
makes no effort to defend himself
because nothing matters to him anymore
depressed and heartbroken bond no longer
has a purpose in life and because he
blames himself for what happened to
Elaine he probably feels that he
deserves to be punished he probably
thinks that he deserves to be locked
away and brutally tortured because he
got to live and become immortal while
the woman he loved lost her life to save
him bond has survivor's guilt he feels
that his life is meaningless and the
only thing that is able to grab his
interest even slightly is meliodas when
the captain of the seven deadly sins
comes to recruit bond bond has no
interest whatsoever but when he realizes
how strong Milly Otis is and that if he
joins he will have the opportunity to
test his strength against Milly Otis
bond decides to join the seven deadly
sins
however the bond that we see at this
time is not the real bond he hides his
deep sadness and despair from his
comrades and he presents himself as just
an eccentric guy who loves fighting
strong opponents and getting very very
drunk without knowing his full backstory
we might mistake bond for a carefree and
immature young guy who only cares about
having a good time and living by his own
rules but in reality bonds heavy
drinking and careless attitude is an
attempt to numb his despair and
heartbreak and his need to keep testing
his strength by facing stronger and
stronger opponents most likely stems
from his resentment or the fact that he
is immortal and cannot die so he is
cursed to live forever without Elaine
and with the terrible guilt he feels
over her death in reality bond keeps
trying to challenge him ally Otis and
other strong fighters because he is
probably hoping that he will eventually
find someone who can actually kill him
and save him from his despair and even
knowing this much we can see that bond
is an interesting and multi-dimensional
character he seems like a fun-loving guy
who enjoyed being reckless getting drunk
fighting and in general having a good
time on the surface bond is basically
the party girl of the seven deadly sins
but beneath the surface he is an
emotional and psychological mess
and this comes into play perfectly when
bond decides to kill meliodas because he
was falsely promised by a goddess that
Elaine will be revived if meliodas dies
bond knows that meliodas saved him when
he recruited him into the seven deadly
sins and gave him some sort of purpose
in life after years of utter depression
and despair melioidosis bonds best
friend and bond admits that aside from
Elaine Mele Otis is the only other
person who truly understands him and yet
bond is so haunted by guilt over what
happened to Elaine that he decides that
killing meliodas his best friend is a
price that he is willing to pay in order
to bring Elaine back thankfully bond
fails to kill Milly auras and as he
realizes the truth behind melioidosis
relationship to Elisabeth and the curse
that has been placed on both of them by
the demon king and the supreme deity
bond is wracked with guilt yet again
this time over the fact that he betrayed
meliodas and tried to kill him for all
these years bond has been so depressed
and heartbroken because the woman he
loved died in his arms but he later
learns that meliodas had to go through
this very same experience with Elisabeth
not once not twice but over a hundred
times bond feels terrible about his own
weakness and his willingness to betray
his best friend just so he could spare
himself the emotional torture of losing
Elaine but Mellie Otis understands how
he feels Mele Otis has lived through
that same hell and he forgives bond
right away it takes some time before
bond can overcome his sense of guilt but
he eventually does he develops and grows
as a character and he eventually comes
full circle now there will be some minor
manga spoilers at this point so just
giving you a quick heads-up right now
after Elaine is revived Bimal aesculus
magic bond actually decides to leave her
and enter purgatory in order to save
Mele Otis's emotions from the demon king
bond goes from trying to kill his best
friend in order to revive Elaine -
leaving Elaine and his other friends and
entering the notoriously treacherous
realm of purgatory knowing full well
that he may never see Elaine or his
other friends again bond is so committed
to helping his friend and making things
right after betraying him in the past
and this to me is truly amazing
character development but we're not done
yet eventually we learn about Vaughn's
backstory and how he grew up he was a
poor boy who had to steal just to
survive and he was brutally mistreated
by society he was beaten abused and he
was almost sold into slavery to a sick
maniac nobleman thankfully bond met Joe
vago a werefox who saved him from the
human traffickers and in general taught
him how to survive and treated him as
his own son because he was aware Fox
Chicago had to assume human form to
avoid being brutally murdered because
the humans considered all Beast men
including we're foxes to be dangerous
monsters in fact Shivaji OHS biological
son was eventually hunted down and
murdered by humans even though he was
just a boy and as a result of this
incident bond lost touch with Zhivago
and he basically lost his only real
mentor and parental figure until he
finally meets him again much later in
life bonds back story is truly
heartbreaking and I am not ashamed to
say that I shed a tear or ten when I
read it in the manga and then again when
I saw it animated in season 2 of the
anime after everything he went through
after being beaten abused and faced with
mistreatment and discrimination on a
daily basis we might expect bond to
become a harsh and cold person we might
expect him to never trust anyone and to
be willing to do whatever it takes to
survive without regard to whether his
actions are good or evil after all if he
was mistreated all his life why should
he treat anyone else with respect and
compassion why shouldn't he just become
a brooding jaded man who is angry at the
world and everyone around him but bond
doesn't become angry and jaded we see
this when he first meets Elaine even
though as a bandit he has a reputation
for being greedy in reality he isn't and
he gives up his quest for the Fountain
of Youth after he meets Elaine because
he fell in love with Elaine and he
decided that being with her is much more
important than immortality when he loses
Elaine bond does experience heavy
psychological and emotional torture he
is tempted again to give up on life and
to become angry and jaded and perhaps he
does for a time but eventually we see
his true self emerge once again as he
one of the seven deadly sins as he makes
friends with Mellie Otis and the others
and as he struggles to overcome the loss
of Elaine even before Elaine is revived
we can see the growth and bonds
character by how he treats the people
around him including Mellie Otis Hawke
and Jericho but also King Elizabeth II
and so on even though he is haunted by
his tragic past and even though he feels
terrible guilt and despair bond still
treats others with compassion he still
jokes with them drinks with them
competes with them and laughs with them
despite everything he went through bond
is still a fundamentally good kind and
compassionate person and as the story
goes on this becomes more and more
evident I don't want to spoil too much
for those of you who haven't read the
manga
although the manga is amazing and I
definitely recommend checking it out but
bond eventually develops a technique
that is able to give energy to other
people rather than merely steal the
energy of others and of course stealing
objects and even the power of other
individuals was the fox's scent of
Reid's original special ability but as
he learns this new technique that gives
rather than taking away the development
of bonds physical power mirrors his
development as a character I think that
the seven deadly sins story handles
bonds development perfectly and he is
truly a multi-dimensional and nuanced
character that I cannot help but love he
starts off as an eccentric and
mysterious antihero with a dark past but
he becomes a full-fledged hero a
dedicated lover a faithful friend and an
all-around great person he might have a
reputation for being a greedy drunken
masochist and there is some truth to
these claims but bond is so much more
than that
he is a fictional character in a fantasy
Shonen anime / manga but he feels like a
real person because his character is so
well written and so thoroughly developed
and let's face it he also has an amazing
and utterly badass character design but
that's not quite as important all in all
bond this greedy drunken masochist is
one of my favorite anime characters of
all time he feels like a complete
complex and relatable individuals
someone we would all love to have a beer
with but at the same
time I wouldn't be afraid to shut a tear
over his heartbreaking past and his
unbreakable determination to keep moving
forward and that is why we all love bond
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more you can leave a like to let
me know if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and finally I want to
say a big thank you to everyone who has
been supporting anime up or on patreon
both now and in the past if you want to
support more content on this channel
feel free to check out our patreon page
link in the description let me know what
you guys think about bond down in the
comments is he your favorite 7 Deadly
Sins character or do you prefer someone
else and feel free to hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar if
you have any requests for future videos
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]